is it nice to be out of the culture wars
and actually closer to your realm of
expertise now you know it's thank you
for that opening question when you are
in the culture wars by definition you're
in a war you're in a war on reason on
Logic on evidence-based thinking on
Common Sense on reality and so even
though I may be a affable happy person
just the sheer fact of the that you have
to take on these issues causes your
cortisol levels to go up because you're
constantly fighting against someone uh
not physically of course but in terms of
the ideological battle so it's so
refreshing to be able to talk not just
about something that is you know within
the realm of psychology and well-being
but positive psychology right I'm not
talking about OCD and about uh
depression I'm talking about arguably
the topic that philosophers have most
written about which is how do we lead a
good life yeah something
maybe less contentious but uh equally
contested and equally confusing to many
people trying to break down What
happiness is so your background is in
evolution which I've taken a massive
interest in over the last couple of
years why would it be the case in your
opinion that Evolution would curse
humans with the ability to feel chronic
prolonged existential angst and
dissatisfaction and unhappiness
what a great uh question that gets my uh
cerebral juices going uh look so let
I'll answer this in a roundabout way
uh if you look at some of the dark side
consumption acts that we succumb to so
to your point about succumbing to these
things so pornographic addiction uh
compulsive buying Eating Disorders
excessive Sun Tanning uh pathological
gambling why would we if we are adaptive
creatures ever succumb to these
behavioral traps and so what I argue in
answering that question which can then
serve as a oblique answer to your
question
is that oftentimes what happens with
each of these phenomena is you take an
Adaptive mechanism that misfires and
it's that misfiring that then leads to
the maladaptive Behavior so for example
when you look at a compulsive buying
it's almost exclusively women who suffer
from compulsive buying about 90 percent
and they're they don't compulsively buy
lawn mowers and digital cameras they
pathologically purchase compulsively
purchase
beautification products so what's
happening there is you're taking an
Adaptive mechanism which in this case is
a sex specific one how do I ameliorate
my lot in The Mating market and then it
just consistently misfires so it becomes
maladaptive so I think a similar kind of
framework might explain the question
that you're talking about
is happiness adaptive in your experience
or in your view well so it's interesting
that you asked us again because there is
a whole field
so there's a field called evolutionary
medicine which tries to incorporate
evolutionary principles in the practice
of medicine and it may or may not
surprise many of your viewers and
listeners
that very few Physicians are trained in
evolutionary thinking they might know
Anatomy they might know physiology but
they are stuck in what's called
proximate World they understand the how
and the what of a mechanism they're not
the ultimate not the ultimate not the
ultimate darwinian why right and
therefore so now take evolutionary
medicine apply it to a sub-specialty of
medicine in Psychiatry or Clinical
Psychology and there is a very very
small group of whether it be
psychiatrists or clinical psychologists
who apply The evolutionary lens in their
practice was on the show a couple of
months ago well Randy Nessie is a very
good friend of mine and who's been on my
show several times and actually if I may
engage in a bit of uh uh tooting my horn
not like you God not like me exactly I'm
a modest gun no but I but it's in the
context of something that I'm trying to
say I'm not just trying to share my CV
with you uh I think we are both
recipients of an award from the applied
evolutionary psychology Society him for
infusing evolutionary thinking into
medicine and me infusing it in consumer
behavior and marketing and economic
decision making and so on So Randy is a
phenomenal guy and he was actually
recently on my show so an evolutionary
Psychiatry you might ask questions like
why would what's what's the evolution
explanation for OCD for depression and
so on now the flip side is happiness
adaptive I don't think we have a domain
again I'm going to use evolutionary
terms we don't have a domain General
mechanism for seeking happiness right so
it's not that I say I want to wake up
today and maximize some abstract metric
called Happiness but I do have domain
specific computational mechanisms which
if I pursue them optimally should lead
to happiness so finding the appropriate
mate there are all sorts of
computational systems in my brain and
yours that have evolved to solve that
problem now if I make that choice well
the downstream effect will be that I'll
probably have a happier life
does this mean
one way to conceptualize this would be
that happiness is an aggregate view of
the contributing parts of the little
Pursuits and things and approaches and
mindsets that you go about each
different day I think so that that's
exactly right as most things in life
most phenomena they're multifactorial
right there isn't a singular factor that
results in you having high blood
pressure there might be several it might
be partly genetic it might be your
grossly overweight it might be you are
eating too much salt each of these are
contributing to that ultimate metric the
exact same thing happens to happiness
that's why I mean I
in the book the title has eight secrets
for leading the good life I chose those
there wasn't a magical reason why I
chose eight not nine and why those eight
not some other eight because those seem
to me when I didn't kind of
autobiographical introspection they were
some of the ones that were most
contributing to my own sense of
well-being you had this interesting
Insight zebras and other prey animals
experience momentary stress which
triggers a flight mechanism and this is
compared with humans ability to have
this sort of protracted ambient kind of
Specter of stress that's going on
and indeed so Robert sapolsky have you
have you ever chatted with Robert
this is the first time I'm going to say
it sapolski's coming on to talk about
his new book determined in the middle of
October so for the sapolsky fans out
there we're going to have him on for his
new book about free will oh that's
wonderful so uh sapolsky uh wrote a book
many years ago called uh why zebras
don't get ulcers or I think I got the
title right and where he's basically
arguing exactly the quote that you just
read which is look a prey animal doesn't
sit around as far as We Know
with an existential you know uh you know
looming thought you know why why do I
live in a world where there are so many
nasty predators and how can I imagine
right they have a autonomic mechanism in
this case they're prey animals so they
will flee if they see a danger that is
worth activating the autonomic system
they flee if they are able to
successfully activate the system they'll
live to graze another day and if not
it's going to be a very very ugly death
whereas humans because of this
prefrontal cortex which offers us many
benefits but also offers us some
drawbacks
uh we we don't always live in the moment
right we we so for example I talk about
regret later in the in the book which is
something that I'm looking in the past
why did I do this or why didn't I do
that and we're also looking at the
future so oftentimes when people suffer
from anxiety disorders because they are
uh placing too great a scanning on so
many possibilities that may happen what
if this happens what if this happens
what if that happens and that will raise
my cortisol levels zebras as far as we
know don't have that and therefore they
they can go about peacefully grazing
while we uh obsess over the past and the
future
being stressed as a human must be
energetically expensive right it causes
all manner of your brain takes up a
massive amount of energy and you're
ruminating about things and maybe but
the bottom line is it has to be a net
win adaptively for you to have this
whether you want to call it the the
smoke detector principle right but a
smoke detector principle now smeared
across almost all emotions smeared
across almost all of the concerns that
you could have so yeah it it's what it
really kind of helped me I read a Robert
writes why Buddhism is true and that
really helped that was one of the first
books that I read that kind of helped to
frame it that
look
you are fighting kind of you're swimming
Upstream if you manage to live a happy
life a consistently happy life because
you weren't built to be happy you were
built to be a grandchild optimizing
machine and and then and then get out of
the way
um so yeah I I some people get
despondent when they learn about
evolutionary psychology uh for me it
gave me an odd kind of Solace I think
well uh so a couple of points out first
regarding the stress in one of the to
continuing on the sapolsky thread uh in
one of the chat early chapters uh I have
an entire chapter on what the ancient
Greeks already knew very much although I
offer a much broader literature review
if you like of that phenomenon the
everything in moderation mechanism which
I talk about it in the context of the
inverted U curve I'll come to stress in
a second bear with me so uh the inverted
U is basically the idea that too little
of something is not good too much of
something is not good and somewhere in
the middle is The Sweet Spot and what I
argue in that chapter is that life
ultimately ends up being
the pursuit of that sweet spot across
many many otherwise disparate domains
one of which and hence I come to
sapolsky now is that he demonstrated
that stress itself follows the inverted
u-curve meaning if I don't experience
any stress that's not going to lead to
good outcomes if I experience too much
stress that I'm frozen and I can't go to
the exam because I'm too stressed to do
it that's not going to be good if I'm
not stressed enough then I don't study
enough for the exam I I face no fear of
failure and so even stress follows that
inverted you regarding your other point
of course I'm delighted that you you
know you found a love and appreciation
for evolution psychology
it's one that if I'm not sure if we
discussed the last time that I came on
your show uh even if we did it's worth
repeating and if it's not it's good that
we're saying it for the first time the
way that I was first exposed to
Evolution Psychology was a first
semester as a doctoral student at
Cornell where I had been uh it had been
suggested to me that I take an advanced
social psychology course with Professor
Dennis Regan so this was not an
evolutionary psychology course and about
maybe halfway through the semester he
assigned a book by two of the pioneers
of evolutionary psychology a husband and
wife team Martin Daly and Margo Wilson
uh where the book is titled homicide
where they looked at patterns of
criminality around the world and across
time periods and demonstrate
demonstrated that there are some very
very elegant parsimonious theoretically
coherent Ways by which you could explain
these using an evolutionary lens
my mind was blown that's where I had my
Epiphany and so that's I mean it's
literally that book that then made me
say I'm going to do exactly what they
did but instead of it being for
criminality I'm going to use it for
psychology of decision making for
Consumer psychology and so on and that's
how I became an evolutionary
psychologist but it wasn't my intention
of I mean originally when I went for my
PhD it was to be a mathematical modeler
I have a background in mathematics so I
was going to model economic choice and
consumer choice but I always had an
interest in Behavioral Sciences so then
I slightly switched and then eventually
I found that book and I became an
evolutionary behavioral scientist
mathematics is way more boring you made
the right decision I think my uh
probably you would have never invited me
on your Shore if I was a math geek you
know probably well it depends what
you're talking about so yeah I am my
book my coming-of-age red pill was the
moral animal Robert Wright's first one I
mean what's that 91 92 93.
and maybe a bit later could it be 95
well dude nearly 30 years and it still
holds up it's still there's some stuff
that's like less so but uh largely it's
phenomenal okay so getting back to this
conception of Happiness one of the
things that we need to do is kind of
Define terms when people think about
happiness what do you what would you say
that most people get wrong like what
what isn't happiness yes it's usually uh
the mixing of short-term hits of
dopamine with long-term serotonin
contentment if I can put it in a
neuroanatomical framework right so uh
yes buying the Aston Martin might make
me happy yes buying another pair of
super expensive stiletto shoes if I'm a
woman who Hoards these might make me
temporarily quote happy but here we're
talking about a sense of existential
happiness I'm sitting on the proverbial
porch I'm 85 years old I'm looking back
at my life my wife is sitting next to me
I'm saying we've done well right we've
had a great life we've had a great
marriage we've raised great kids
uh you know I've had a profession that
has brought me immense purpose and
meaning so it's in that sense so it's
not those short uh ephemeral fleeting
moments of quote Joy it's really the
long-term existential View
yeah that's an interesting way to look
at it the um
this difference between happiness and
satisfaction and peace and contentment
and pleasure and the way that it all
kind of fractures together is an
interesting one based on your research
how much do you think that we can move
our happiness purposely so very early in
the book I try to address your question
by
making the point that about 50 percent
of individual differences across people
in terms of their happiness comes from
their genes because I want to recognize
off the bat that yes it is true that
some of us are just through the
randomness of the genetic Lottery are
born with a more sunnier disposition and
so I may we have a sunny or disposition
than you Chris but I'm British I'm
British that's true that's true uh but
that doesn't mean that we are
deterministically doomed to wherever
ours because 50 due to genes implies
there's 50 up for grabs that's the
that's the half the glass half full
right and so there are endless Ways by
which I could make certain decisions
Implement certain mindsets that
irrespective of where I started based on
my genetic lottery I can either improve
or worsen and so
yeah this kind of relates to a personal
anecdote which is for most of my 20s I
was pretty sure that I was depressed
that I had I would regularly spend you
know every four months or so I'd spend a
couple of days in bed and I wouldn't
really want to get out of bed and and I
wouldn't want to speak to people and the
curtains would be drawn uh and then
there was just this sort of ambient
sense of something being amiss and you
know maybe it was seasonal affective
disorder from living in the northeast of
the UK maybe it was from poor sleep and
wake Cycles because I was running
nightclubs so it meant that I was all
over the place uh that also meant that
not much but I was partying once every
three weeks or so and I'd be hungover
and it would reset my Habit to all this
sort of stuff
one of the things that I've noticed
since moving to a much sunnier much
generally more positive and much more
consistent sleep wake each drink cycle
than I had previously
part of me is very happy because I feel
better day to day but there's another
element which is almost a benefit that
people could use to offset this sort of
despondence and nihilism that you can
feel oh I only have control over 50 of
my happiness I still remember the anchor
of what it was like when I didn't feel
so good so the fact that my happiness
set point could sort of be a bit more
ambivalent it could go either way almost
gives me a lower bar that I can recall
you know it's I I don't need as much
money because I came up Working Class
Type scenario it's the the happiness
equivalent
well so I I'm not sure if it exactly uh
follows from what you're saying but
paradoxically the fact that I've gone
through some difficult periods at
various points but certainly in my
childhood as a war Refugee child war
Refugee in Lebanon allowed me so in your
case you're you're contrasting you know
I come from a you know difficult
blue-collar background and I can
contextualize whatever I'm going through
now against that the backdrop of that
well whenever I feel like whining to
myself about all sorts of daily things
you know I mean I I I've used this
example on a few shows recently but but
it's it's a really powerful one so
forgive me if anybody has already heard
it you know as I was going on this you
know massive media tour for you know to
promote and discuss the book at times
you're overwhelmed like oh God I gotta
go here I've got to do this I've got
seven shows and so on and then I would
kind of stop myself my internal voice
would say wait a minute are you
genuinely whining to yourself that a
whole bunch of really interesting people
are giving you the opportunity to talk
about your book remember that you
escaped by a miracle the Lebanese Civil
War so snap out of it stop whining and
then that would quickly get me back on
track like yeah I'm gonna speak to Chris
today and tomorrow I got this guy
so I think using some of those difficult
moments as catalysts to contextualize
why we're feeling bad is an immediate
happy pill if we can know how to use it
properly
you say that there are key life
decisions that are the purveyors of
either great misery or immense happiness
the two most important of these are
choosing the right life partner and the
ideal job profession
why why those two
so let's just go through your temporal
timeline uh you wake up
and when you wake up someone is sitting
next lying next to you that person is
someone that could either make me go oh
God another day next to this person God
please strike me or I could say oh my
God I can't believe I'm waking up to
this lovely creature every day so
already that's either taking me in the
bifurcation this way or that way now I
put on my clothes and I go off
proverbially to whatever my job is where
I'm gonna spend much of my day that can
is either gonna make me go oh yes some
exciting stuff happening today whatever
it is or not that's another bifurcation
and then after that day I come back to
that person that I either hate or really
love so it basically pretty much covers
my every second of every day so if I
make those two decisions well now of
course by the way I don't have the the
hubris or the false promise to say I
guarantee you that I'm going to offer
you the prescription of how to choose
the right job and the right mate but
what I can tell you is there are some
maxims that you can follow that can
statistically increase your chance of
Happiness right so my book contrary to
most quote self-help books it has the
epistemic humility to say I'm not gonna
give you the guaranteed Secrets life is
about navigating through statistical
vagaries and so I'm going to offer you
some recipes that will hopefully
increase your chances just like to draw
an analogy uh
non-smokers get lung cancer and they
didn't smoke ever in their lives but
it's certainly the case it is
statistically true that if I don't smoke
boy do I reduce my chances of
Contracting lung cancer so in that sense
I offer some prescriptions for how to
choose the right mate how to choose the
right job which we're going to talk
about yeah absolutely so when it comes
to a mate if you're doing your uh recipe
for a non-miserable life what are the
ingredients right so here and of course
going back to I love that you love
Evolution psychology there are a couple
of opposing maxims there's the Opposites
Attract Maxim and then there is the
birds of a feather flock together Maxim
or in the fancy language and evolution
psychology is a sortative mating right
we are sorting on something like what
that's similar well it turns out that
for the the likelihood of achieving
long-term success in a union in a
marriage in a long-term relationship
it's over overwhelmingly the case that
birds of a feather flock together is the
greater likelihood of you succeeding now
the next question then that begs to be
asked is well but a sorting on which
feathers right so is it that we have to
have the same eye color is it that we
have to have the same hair color of
course the answer is that we have to
assort on the foundational values our
our our our fundamental values our
fundamental belief systems the more they
are congruent with each other the the
greater the likelihood of us having a
happy Union and again that should be
reasonably obvious to most people think
about it in the following way
if I happen to be incredibly faith-based
in my day-to-day I'm a very religious
person and the prospective partner that
I might decide to be together with we
have great chemistry and we we love the
same literature and so on but she
happens to be acoustic atheist well it
doesn't take much of a fancy Evolution
psychologist to say that all other
things equal we already are seeing a bit
of a fissure that is likely developing
in our future if every single action in
my day is Guided by my you know faith
and you and you think it's all
we're gonna we're gonna probably have
trouble so for example my wife and I
we're both Lebanese now I I didn't
specifically set out to find only a
Lebanese you know prospective spouse but
the fact that she is Lebanese
made it so much more likely that our
cultural Compass points would be
identical so for example the first day
that I went to meet her parents uh we
sat down to play shesh Besh which is
like backgammon right okay and so as I
played with her dad I looked at her dad
I said uh sir if I win I get to keep
your daughter and he said okay well if I
would have made this joke in a home
where they were where they studied at
Oberlin College maybe I they would have
been offended that I was being a
patriarchal Pig and so on but he
understood the joke and so on and so
these momentary things once you share
the same belief systems the same humor
the same culture simply increase your
chances of leading a happy life what are
the other in your opinion big movers
that people should be optimizing for
similarity on Beyond religious worldview
yeah so it could be for example I am
incredibly driven and the person that
I'm with is quite apathetic and by the
way that the example that I just gave is
much more problematic if the apathetic
one happens to be the male right because
many men may forgive
the apathy in the workplace of their no
man has ever said this you are gorgeous
you have a beautiful body I'd love to
have sex with you but you're not
exhibiting the requisite amount of
ambition no sex for you Linda the
opposite has certainly happened right
and so so all of these kind of Life
trajectory metrics so beyond religion
but these really important foundational
mechanisms by which I tackle life the
more we assort on those the more we're
going to be happy the by the way the
singular um this is this is something
that I discussed very very briefly in
the book so it's not really important
but for completeness the singular metric
from an evolutionary perspective where
humans engage in disassortative mating
do you know what it is
this assortment is I look I look for
someone who's maximally different from
me no
so it's it's on what's called MHC the
major histocompatibility complex which
is a set of genetic markers that code
for your unique immunological profile
which is the Ashkenazi Jews
well I mean that's that's a kind of an
ethnic thing but it's picked up through
your smell so how do we know by the way
remember earlier I said that Randy
Nessie and myself had both won this
award this award the other guy who is
also on it is the guy who's done the
research that I'm about to tell you
about I think if I remember correct his
name is Craig Roberts based out of uh
Britain
so the studies basically work as follows
I'm going to ask a bunch of men to wear
a t-shirt let's say a white T-shirt uh
so that it it becomes imbued with their
smell I mean don't don't go and run a
marathon just go about doing your daily
routine then I'm gonna ask them to take
it off I'm gonna put it in a plastic bag
and I'm going to ask women to come and
smell each of those shirts and to rate
them on attractiveness and it turns out
Chris that's the beauty of evolution
psychology that the one that people
choose is the one that is maximally
different from their MHC can you forgive
me I hope I'm not putting it on the spot
but since you are a budding evolutionary
psychologist or at least lover of
English psychology can you guess what
would be the Adaptive reason for that
because the way that passing down an
immune system to your child works is by
trying to cover as many holes potential
holes as possible
look at you Doctor Chris Dr Chris hey
hey let me give you this I got cited in
my first ever paper a couple of months
ago congratulations do you remember what
the journal was
uh I will be able to I'll have to find
you uh that it's David Buss and William
Costello and it is my theory of the male
sedation hypothesis explaining why we
haven't seen more in cell violence
despite young male syndrome being a uh
sort of vestigial
um Trend I love that well I can I can
see why David Buss would cite that who's
a very good friend of mine now of course
who lives in Austin with with whom I
don't usually like to walk around with
given that I come up roughly to his
knees
he's a giant human yeah it's not very
good for my testosterone levels uh to
walk around and I come up to his ankles
that's not a good feeling but then I can
remind people that I am the same height
as Lionel Messi so he's done well so
maybe I could let me give you this so I
learned this from Scott Galloway in 1960
one in 25 parents had concerns about
their child marrying someone from the
opposite political party by 2018 almost
half of democrat parents and a third of
Republican parents had such concerns yes
you're you're citing this in the context
of assorting with people who are similar
to us uh yeah look uh
yes I mean you want me to comment on it
or it was just a statement yeah well I
was
look it depends right I mean if if
having differences in political
orientations results as as I suspect it
would in huge foundational differences
and values then I think that's going to
be a problem although as I of course
explain in much of my work and certainly
in the parasitic mind you also don't
want to fall trap uh to the echo chamber
reality but I do agree that for example
if I am a hugely anti-walk professor as
I am and my wife happens to be the most
outlandish blue-haired Taliban from
Oberlin I don't care that I am the model
of masculine epitome and she is a
gorgeous woman we're probably not going
to get along right so so that doesn't
yeah especially given the fact that
political orientation is
like highly heritable you know this you
can predict quite well what your son or
daughter are going to be based on what
you and your partner are so it's not
just some abstract sort of decision that
you decide to make your political
inclination is largely informed by you
and the structure that imbues you which
means that a lot of the other things
will be Downstream from that you know
it's like the correlation between the
number of people that go to the it's
like this uh going to the gym is a
right-wing phenomenon thing like the
reason that it's there is I would guess
that on average probably people who are
right of Center and further right we'll
go to the gym more because they will
have the Constitution that is that of
somebody that does I would guess that
they're going to be uh Less open right
so they'll probably be more if you were
to say I want to be with an artist it's
like you better hope that you kind of
are probably Center left or left of that
because you there's not going to be as
many like cool long ahead guitar players
and and budding illustratists on the
right hand side well to exactly to that
point about going to the gym and
political orientation you may or may not
remember that in the parasitic mind uh I
talked about male feminists as an
instantiation of the sneaky
strategy which has since become kind of
a meme now just for people to know in
case they start writing you idiotic
comments the concept of sneaky is
not mine it it came up in in Zoology in
the 1970s applying that mechanism to
explain May of feminists is what I did
right basically what I was arguing is
that what male feminists are doing is
manifesting that strategy that we see in
the animal kingdom right look at me I am
I am sensitive I'm I'm empathetic I hug
trees therefore you shouldn't be afraid
to hang around me okay but to your point
about the physical strength with going
to the gym in that section in the
parasitic mind I cite some beautiful
work not not my work by others where
they demonstrate that physical strength
predicts political orientation right now
that to me is a is a
finding that passes the that's
interesting exclamation point framework
in doing research again let me step back
and explain this there's a 1971 paper
that I think everyone should read but
certainly doctoral students it's a paper
written by Davis who is a sociologist I
think he's passed away now and that the
title of the paper was that's
interesting exclamation point where he
was offering a framework for how do you
judge whether research is worthy to
pursue like what is the metric of
interestingness that you should you know
establish and decide because oftentimes
what people do when they're judging the
value of research is is it is it
methodologically rigorous is it
theoretically coherent and often what
I've done in my long career as a
professor when I'm reviewing papers is I
say yes it passes theoretical coherence
it passes my The Logical rigor the
literature review is great but guess
what it's pure when it comes to
anything novel or interesting or
surprising that we wouldn't have
Otherwise Known well that finding of
linking physical strength or morphology
to political orientation is a link that
heretofore had not been made and
therefore in my view that's a perfect
demonstration of that's interesting
exclamation point research
are married people more happy
they are so the research showed that
there is a bit of a uh a positive
correlation uh for all sorts of I think
obviously now that doesn't mean of
course that if you choose that you're
not going to be happy you're doomed to a
life of misery and unhappiness these are
statements that you're making at the
population level so we can all find
individual cases that invalidate this
right men are taller than women even
though you're uh your Aunt Linda is
taller than your Uncle Bob okay and I
always get this when I'm lecturing on
Evolution psychology so yes there is a
protective belt that comes in terms of
Happiness by being married now let's
come up with a very uh basic anecdote
that supports this from my personal life
so I lost a lot of weight uh over the
past few years and I don't think I'm
being uh
uh unnecessarily uh complementary to my
wife and saying that it would have
probably been impossible for me to do it
if I didn't have her as a partner why
number one she was doing all of the
cooking that went into this otherwise
fat big gluttonous mouth number one
number two she was the one who was
keeping track of all my calories on an
app so that come eight o'clock at night
when I otherwise might still have
another 400 calories of consuming in me
she says hey you're at 1643. shut your
mouth for the rest of the day if I
didn't have that partner who completely
gave me the confines the limitations of
what are the behavioral things that I
should do it's not that I'm not smart
enough to do it but is that I did I
wouldn't have had the structure to do it
well guess what if nothing else I can
attribute a large amount of my weight
loss to having that partner so yes being
married makes you happier you yeah it's
um I was talking to Dr Robert waldinger
from the oh yes I had him recently on
the show yeah he was great and you know
it really does seem like relationships
there's a very odd tension or Paradox
that's happening at the moment in the
modern world on one hand there is this
kind of atomized individualized escapism
trend you know it it comes up in all
different sorts of flavors whether it be
girl boss or Sigma Lone Wolf grind set
Bro or uh the despondent black pill or
you know like there's a lot of different
ways that you can slice this but what it
all Nets out to is I don't need to
interact with the rest of the world I'm
going to do this on my own I don't need
anybody and
I wonder whether the effect of marriage
especially on longevity especially for
men like if you're a guy that wants to
live longer like you better have a
partner of some kind and I mean and it's
literally the forgive me for
interrupting the example that I gave is
literally that right how much did she
add to my life by me losing eight years
pounds yes
literally years of lifespan yep exactly
sorry were you gonna say something else
so just the fact that because we have uh
more individualized more atomized than
ever before Society I think that you're
going to
even more so benefit from having the
partner right I think uh um Dunbar says
that in order to get into a relationship
you need to take up two of the five
close friend slots because that's how
much it is but conversely you could look
at your partner as being worth two good
friends yes right um so you know whether
that's from an emotional support
perspective whether that's from an
enjoyment of Life fun having a variety
of experience longevity so yeah I think
um
ignore the happiness and lifespan
advantages of a long-term partner at
your peril yes it beautifully said so a
couple of couple of points I want to add
to what you said so I do quote Robert
waldinger in my happiness book
specifically as you know he's the direct
the current director of the eight plus
decade long uh Harvard adult development
study or I can't remember the exact
title that basically tries to look at
what are the the factors longitudinally
that that increase well-being both
physical well-being and you know mental
well-being and uh I think it was one of
his quotes that I used in the book uh
where he basically was saying that if
you look at uh your health in your I
think it was in your 80s uh
the quality of relationships that you
have is a greater predictor than your
cholesterol levels right now
incidentally I've had a few Physicians
on and I've asked them well but what's
the mechanism I mean I get that that's
the the correlate and the general
argument that I've had and I don't know
if it's a speculative one or not is that
it actually reduces a lot of the
inflammation markers uh that that that
you know being well surrounded by people
that you trust that you know have your
back that you love that you care for and
but now bringing you back to the the
partner the the wife in my case I've
been fortunate enough that my wife is
also my best friend in other words we've
been together for 23 years while I have
male friends and I love to hang out with
them and there's a different Dynamic
there
I've never had the desire nor has she to
have bro night out and girls night out
once we got together we were able to
satisfy luckily all of our needs whether
it be our friend need our remote now
that doesn't mean that we've isolated
ourselves from a greater social network
but if you're able to find someone to go
back to our earlier point that you you
really love to be around right we're
constantly joking with each other right
I mean you you were I hope earlier were
joking about when I said oh I'm going to
tooth my horn and you right but well she
she ripped on me because at one point I
tell the story in the book you know I
had lost a lot of weight so I was
looking a lot more muscular so I walk
into the kitchen without my shirt and I
say look at this and she kind of ignores
me I say how are you ignoring this
gorgeous guy and then she said you know
what we need to call some contractors to
try to strengthen the foundations of
this house because your ego seems to be
perhaps too heavy for this house well
this ability to rib at each other not
take our ourselves seriously engage in
self-deprecation boy that's a recipe for
happiness talk to me about sex how much
sex should we be having if we want to be
happy well so here the in answering that
question I'm going to refer to a section
in the book where I say that happiness
is a positional emotion and I'm gonna
you mean like missionary
no no I'm not talking about uh specific
positions no but yes well well played
well played uh no so what I mean here is
that if you look at the link between
happiness and sex it's not going to
surprise anybody that's listening that
on average having more sex leads to more
happiness but the next part is the
that's interesting exclamation point
part which is it's not enough for me to
have sex or more sex to be happy it's
important to me if Chris you're a good
friend of mine that I have more sex than
you now I'm really happy so I gotta have
a lot of sex and I have to have more sex
than all of my friends that's my ticket
to happiness now why why is that
important in a grander sense
because we are a social species we are a
hierarchical species a lot of the way by
which the calculus that we use in
judging where we fit in the grand lot of
life is how do we compare to others
keeping up with the Joneses if you want
to use a consumer psychology example so
it's not enough for me to just have sex
I need to hopefully be friends with a
lot of monks and cells celibate nuns or
in cells then I'll be really happy right
very interesting
yeah so all of Dan bilzerian's friends
are miserable presumably who was that
what did you mention Dan Bilzerian he's
like the modern the modern Hugh Hefner
he's like a Hugh Hefner of of 2023. oh
is that right okay flies around the
world on on private jets and he's got
like 20 women with him at all times and
all this sort of stuff one interesting
point I remember Chris Delia talking
about this and he said
um you look at Dan bilzerian's life and
you think all of these women on tap and
they're all supermodels and all this
stuff but then as soon as you finished
having sex and all 20 of them are on the
private jet talking about like what
makeup foundation they're going to use
or did you watch the episode of the
Kardashians last night like that
I I it's a heavy price to pay to live
that lifestyle I think to be to
permanently kind of be around like La
party girls but anyway
when it comes to picking the right job
yes sir one of the challenges that I can
foresee is if you love your job a little
bit and it gives you meaning and purpose
you can then become a workaholic to the
detriment of everything else that you're
supposed to do in your life so having a
good job is important but going back to
The Virtuous meme that we were talking
about before
you can over index on Goods job get a
better reward work a bit more get a bit
more reward work a bit more look back on
your life and one of the most common
deathbed regrets I've got it written on
my whiteboard on my fridge at the moment
is I wish I hadn't worked so much yes
absolutely so uh here we're if you like
speaking about several chapters one is
you mentioned the the inverted you as
relating to workaholism uh so you're
exactly right and then the regret is in
the in the LA one of the ending chapters
in the book uh I talk about uh the the
psychology of regret and the one of the
Pioneers who studied it is actually I
was fortunate enough to have him as my
professor in my PhD his name is Thomas
gilovich who pioneered the although I
mean he wasn't the first one to note the
differences between these two sources of
regret he certainly is the one who
empirically studied it in many many
different studies they regret due to
action versus regret due to inaction so
regret due to action is uh I regret that
I cheated on my wife and that resulted
in the dissolution of my marriage and I
so regret that action regret due to
inaction is I regret that I never
pursued
my deep interest for architecture and
and and painting because that's really
what I was meant to do that's what
really drives my juices but I decided to
become a pediatrician because my dad was
one and his dad was one and now I'm 80
and you know frankly I hate that I was a
physician I that's not what I was
passionate about and
to your point about the the the the
quote that you have about regret I then
quote Ronnie Ware who's a palliative
nurse who you know was dealing with
people who are literally on their
deathbed and she tracked all of their
key regrets and the top five one of them
is you know I wish I had lived an
authentic life or something of that
effect and in this case authentic is a
sense of not authentic that you are a
fake person you're not real I think it's
in the existential sense right like you
know I was meant to be a a professional
soccer player but I decided or my
parents decided that that wasn't a
serious job for me so I decided to go so
so you really want to uh engage in
what's called anticipatory regret which
many people think that regret is a
useless emotion because what's the point
about crying over spilled milk as the
the saying goes but anticipatory regret
is actually forward-looking it allows me
to make decisions that I'm facing in the
future using regret as a key calculus so
anyway give an example of someone very
high profile who did that Jeff Bezos
before he started Amazon and was
thinking about starting Amazon had a
very cushy secure high paying job that
would certainly allow him to have all
his material needs met but the reason
why he decided to take the risk and
start Amazon
is because he said I want to anticipate
the likelihood that in the future I will
look back and regret that I never did
this and that's what compelled him in
the bifurcation of his life led him to
to to pursue Amazon so that's that's one
advantage or benefit of of experiencing
regret the other the secondary Advantage
Chris I think of that regret offers us
is that oftentimes we think that that
which we could hopefully have changed
it's too late for us now to change it
and in many cases it is it's too late
for me now to or it's impossible for me
to be an NBA uh player I'm too old I'm
not good enough I'm too short so that's
not gonna happen so regretting that that
didn't happen is really a wasted effort
but
as I explained in the book I give
several examples I'll mention one of
them here there's a gentleman that I
talk about in the book who uh escaped
with his family as the Nazis were coming
into Germany and moved to Canada he'd
always wanted to be a studious guy but
life circumstances have forced him to
you know to go into business he had a
long career in his 60s he was regretting
lamenting the fact that he had never
gone to school so he said okay you know
I'm in my 60s now I've got time I'm
healthy why don't I go and enroll the
reason I know the story is because it
happened at my University uh so he then
enrolls in an undergraduate degree in
his 60s right when he's 40 years older
than the other students he finishes his
bachelor's he's now in his 70s he says
hey I'm I'm still doing I'm still
ticking I'm still going strong let me
pursue a masters he finishes his Masters
starts his PhD and I can't remember if
it was at 91 or 92 the the the
University newspaper on in the front
page
I think the title was finally a doctor
at 91 or 92 and then within a year of
finishing his PhD he passed away so
that's the purest form of sophism right
I mean he was pursuing this for no other
reason than the purity of knowledge he
wasn't looking for an academic job he
wasn't trying to impress his girlfriend
or his parents he's in his 90s and so I
often tell that story Chris when a
student walks into my office sits down
and says hey professor sad I'm uh you
know I'm 28 now and I'm thinking of
going on to pursue my MBA but I feel
like I'm too old and then I say sit down
let me tell you a story and then at the
end of that story their mouth is open
and they're like thank you that was
really helpful so for many things we
don't need to regret we could still make
changes
how does this perspective on regret
inform the way that you
make decisions in life on a day-to-day
basis
so
so the anticipatory element is one that
I always think about when I'm saying so
let's take a concrete example I can do
one of two things in order to be loved
by some of my highfalutin academic
colleagues I could not engage in some of
my ribbing on folks I could be always
professorial which of course I am if I
go give a talk at Stanford I am very
professorial but I can sort of modulate
my behavior in such a way that whichever
Gatekeepers are the ones that invite us
to the cool academic parties I make sure
that I'm on that list or
I can anticipate what's going to happen
in the future
when I lay my head on the pillow to
sleep and am I going to feel that I was
fraudulent that day because I held back
from speaking and defending the truth
because I wanted some careerist thing
and in my case the biggest regret that I
would feel would be that I wasn't
pathologically authentic I mean to a
fault I I know cases where I've gone
after some issue or someone to a great
detriment to me but at least that left
me whole I didn't have to at night have
bouts of regret for not having done XYZ
which would lead me to insomnia and
feelings of innauthenticity so just that
very personal story is a example of how
I link the calculus of regret with a
deep desire to hopefully always be
authentic yeah I think incorrect action
is mostly a one-time cost but inaction
is probably going to be a recurring
about the things that you didn't do
something else that I was considering I
remember hearing uh I can't remember
whose podcast it was on a really
interesting conception between uh two
forms of happiness or two two sort of
broad buckets of Happiness one would be
more pleasure and one would be more
meaning focused it was the difference
between Daniel Gilbert and Daniel
Kahneman so uh Dan Gilbert had said um
you could spend all of your life day to
day uh on a floaty in the pool with a
cocktail sipping on the cocktail and
even though in retrospect when you look
back there might not have been much done
you would have enjoyed each individual
moment and I think it was Dan Gilbert's
sort of contention that this could
constitute a life where I lived whereas
Kahneman said no what you want to do is
live a life which in retrospect you're
glad that you lived you know you you
look back and you each of these moments
they may not have been fully pleasurable
at the time but they gave you is sort of
imbued this meaning and they were the
right decision and so on and so forth
what I've come to believe I'd be
interested to know what you think is
our personal Constitution
is highly dictatorial when it comes to
where on this particular Spectrum we
should sit so I'm quite ruminative I'm
quite introspective I'm an only child so
I'm going to spend a good amount of time
thinking about the decisions that I
would could should have made what does
this say about me as a person how does
this contribute to my greater sense of
self do I really feel like that was the
right thing to do so on and so forth I
have a number of other friends who would
just happily Breeze through decisions
that they made it's water off a duck's
back it doesn't really matter so in this
way
it's kind of my belief that those people
can optimize more toward the sort of
pleasure side they need to optimize less
for regret minimization because regret
and rumination is just not as much of a
part of their constitution whereas for
me it is and I think that that at least
has helped me to understand why other
people seem to kind of get an easier
ride of it it's like oh god dude you get
to be able to do this thing and you
don't even think about what you you know
you what you missed the gym that morning
because you were hungover and you went
out to the night like do you not like
whip yourself because you didn't feel
like you you know enacted your logos
forward and my best your best Integrity
so yeah what do you think of that
conception yeah well I I mean so
I think you're on your way to either
writing a master's thesis or a PhD
dissertation if that's not been done
because you know you're you're linking
several variables that I'm not sure if
they've been studied in in conjunction
with one another but what I can tell you
is I know of a lot of other research
that that is of a similar spirit so On a
related notion Barry Schwartz at Al
Barry Schwartz is a guy who who's
written I mean a lot of stuff in
Psychology one of which is the the
Paradox of choice which by the way fits
the inverted you which is you know a
classical Economist thing that more
choice is always better whereas he's
basically arguing that no up to a
certain point having more choices is
good and then it becomes detrimental so
it's an inverted you of for example
number of products you choose from
before purchasing something but the
reason why I'm mentioning Barry Schwartz
in relation to you know your excellent
uh uh summation a few minutes ago uh is
that there is a psychometric scale that
might link up with what you're talking
about a personality scale which is
maximizing versus satisficing right so
someone who is a satisfied and people
oftentimes even my students when I say
satisfies they think I'm somehow
mispronouncing satisfy you know it's
satisfies which means it's good enough
right so someone who's a satisficer
let's say in consumer search says I
don't need to pick the top
choice that maximizes my utility I just
need to pick one that passes these
minimal thresholds what I just said is
the psychology of a satisficors whereas
the maximizer is the other case well
there is some research that links how I
score on maximizing and satisficing and
happiness so there is definitely so we
would have to think about
how to quantify or operationalize the
construct that you said but I buy it I'm
with you I think you're on to something
you've got this great quote people with
essentially the same life circumstances
that is the same levels of good health
Prosperity occupation Family Concord and
Personal Achievement can have very
different levels of happiness largely
because of what you've spoken about just
that exactly because I can say I need on
this kind of invisible calculus in my
head I need to reach an overall score of
90 or above the happiness score is 0 to
100 I need to have 90 or above or else I
code it as I'm not a happy person
whereas the satisficer says that as long
as on each of these fundamental life
Pursuits I score 70 or higher I'm going
to be happy so both of these folks might
end up being at the same position one
will end up being dissatisfied the other
one will be satisfied so letting go
to some degree
is a skill that is useful if you want to
become happy
indeed and maybe I can use a specific
example you know one of one of the
things I try to do in the book is to mix
personal anecdotes and anecdotes of
others with ancient wisdoms with
contemporary science and the reason why
I tried to do that is because we are a
storytelling animal and so most people
will will band will will converge to
those powerful stories so let me tell a
story that speaks to exactly your point
so arguably one of if not the most
memorable guest that I've ever had on my
show and just like you I've chatted with
a lot of illustrious people as someone
who's not very famous he's someone who
uh no one would know his name his name
is David McCallum he spent almost uh 30
years in prison I think it was the exact
numbers 29 years in prison for a murder
which he was eventually exonerated of so
he went in I think he was 17 he came out
in you know his I think he was 46 or
something like that and as we were
sitting there the reason I'm telling the
story is it speaks to your point about
letting go right uh as we were sitting
there Chris I looked at him you can by
the way you can go and look up that chat
that we had I think it was maybe five
six years ago on my show and I looked up
I said you know David you you must be
The Reincarnation of Buddha or something
because
you seem to be you're so you feel you're
filled with grace there's no sense of
vengefulness or vindictiveness in you
whereas you're a much better man than I
am because I know that if it were me I
would want to burn the world down and so
he so number one he certainly let go of
that anger number it because he wouldn't
have been able to do the 29 years had he
held on to it he wouldn't be able to
progress with the rest of her's life if
he hung on to it but I'm gonna mention a
third powerful lesson about
contextualizing he he then says to me
well you know I have a sister who was
stricken with cerebral palsy and has
been bedridden for I think it was much
of her life and yet she's able to you
know maintain a sense of well-being and
so on and so viewed from that
perspective I mean I'm paraphrasing his
words but views from his perspective
what I went through is maybe nothing so
the guy who just had 30 years stolen
from his life can still contextualize
whatever horror he's got I mean what Can
you steal more from a person than 30
years of their life and yet he was able
to say well it wasn't really that bad
look at this person who's has it a lot
worse than me boy that's a ticket to
well-being talk to me about the delphic
maxim what role does it play here so the
delphic max well there are several so
the probably the the most famous one of
all delphic maxims is know thyself right
which at first it kind of sounds like a
you see it in a cereal box or on a
bumper sticker but it's actually a
profound point because that's why it has
lasted several thousand years well to
know thyself is exactly what we talked
about earlier about existential
authenticity right if I genuinely know
that I was put on this Earth whether you
you put it in a religious narrative or
not but real I mean Lionel Messi was
engineered to play soccer like you
cannot construct a person that's why
whenever I talk about Lionel Messi if we
can just digress for a second I say not
only is it the greatest of all time he's
the greatest that could ever be because
I can't imagine someone coming out who
can move better who can dribble better I
was a competitive soccer I've seen all
the greatest soccer players it's not
even and close Okay so
the delphic maxim nor thyself says you
better look within yourself at every
bifurcation of life and make those
choices that are consistent with that
Maxim and if you're able to consistently
do that throughout your life at the end
of your life you're going to look back
and you're going to say I I live The
Good Life I Lived an authentic life and
so for me for example the only looming
regret that I have the main one is that
I wasn't able for all sorts of reasons
that were outside my control to
instantiate my soccer Talent uh I I've
always been interested in only two
things in life soccer and becoming a
professor even when I was very young
fortunately I was able to instantiate my
academic uh potential but uh every time
the World Cup rolls around I'm filled
with this incredible Nostalgia why did
we not move to Spain or France out of
Lebanon and why did I not have the why
did I have the injury that I did and so
on so it is what it is
yeah the on we well we both got the same
injury we've both got a ruptured
Achilles which I was talking to you
about the last time that we said yeah
mine is I'm playing pickleball I'm
bouncing around I have zero pain I have
zero Mobility so if there is someone
listening that's ruptured in Achilles if
you do the if you do the work uh you'll
be fine within a year 18 months time
you'll be bouncing around like an idiot
forgetting that it ever happened
um
one thing that kind of plays into my
mind
a little bit here as you're talking
about
the different life paths that we can go
down and retrospectively how we feel and
letting go is
I've
I have a problem with people who say
uh this happened for a reason
so
um your Achilles injury let's say right
oh my Achilles injury happened for a
reason because if I didn't have the
Achilles injury I wouldn't have found my
love of evolutionary psychology and then
had a career that I enjoy learning about
stuff that's interesting the reason I
don't like it is I think it robs
everybody of that agency of how they
managed to alchemize what was a shitty
situation into a good one and
it's a very British thing to say that
it's uh it's a fatalistic approach that
um
almost a good things are the aberration
or the anomaly and not what is to be
expected and also that you're kind of
like you're at the mercy of the world
yeah oh you know that I'm so glad that
that thing didn't happen because then
the world was allowed to bless me with
this thing so hang on a second let's
just say that you were dealt two shitty
cards
and you managed to take one of them and
somehow make an ace out of it like
that's a much more empowering useful
story and I think it's more accurate and
if if I can link what you just said to a
psychometric scale so there's the I
don't know if you pronounce it rotor or
rotter r-o-t-t-e-r it's the classic
scale by the the gentleman of that name
uh looking at locus of control the idea
being is that some people are internal
locus of control driven and I'll explain
in a second what that means other people
are external locus of control what do we
mean by locus of control is where do you
attribute the causality to things that
happen to you in your life so when you
said and while this happened for a
reason that is external locus of control
right it's written in the sky it's God
who willed it it's Destiny it's fate
right now interestingly as a side note
uh there is a mechanism whereby
most people tend to attribute successes
internally and failures externally right
so I did well on the exam because
obviously I'm very smart and I did very
poorly on the exam because that
Professor sat as a real and he's
unfair right now the only sorry is that
the is that the fundamental attribution
exactly it's the fundamental attribution
nailed it applied to in this case the
attributions of causality to your life
exactly that's exactly right and so uh
yeah that that gets you an A plus in
participation uh very good uh now the
only group Chris that doesn't succumb to
that those Rosy lenses are clinically
depressed people and I I briefly
mentioned this in the book now here
there's the classic chicken and egg
question which is is it that people who
have innately a less Rosy attributional
style are more Pro known to becoming
clinically depressed or is it that when
I become clinically depressed I then
wallow in a more accurate attributional
style and the research is not clear I
think like for most of these things it's
a bit of both
but having that Rosy attributional Style
serves as a protection against many of
the vagaries of life I succeeded because
I'm smart I failed because those
consumers are and didn't
recognize my brilliance yeah I've been
very interested in optimism especially
over the last
year and a half since moving to America
I don't know what it is about the
American disposition but the people here
are like pathologically positive and
enthusiastic and energetic and I'm aware
that I've selected for a kind of young
up-and-coming City and the weather's
nice and blah blah blah but um still
like it's it's definitely moved what I
thought was a sort of Titanic anchor
shaped sized weight of my
glass half empty usually
maybe even negativity masquerading as
sort of intellectual uh sophistication
in some ways right you know like
cynicism people hide behind it because
it makes them seem like they're much
more
um well thought out it's it's very it's
very easy to be called naive for being
positive but no one ever gets called
naive for being negative right um which
is true and uh you've got this really
lovely quote where you say genuine hope
or optimism is an all-purpose Elixir to
life so I know that it's possible to
cultivate a sense of optimism because
it's happened to me in a very short
space of time to change the way that I
see things happening I I presume that
things are going to go well I'll give
you the the reason why I think this is
interesting and related
we do not know ourselves fully we do not
know the world fully we cannot fully
accurately predict the things that are
going to happen therefore many of the
things and predictions that you have
running through your mind are delusions
so why not choose a delusion that's
going to make your life better and more
enjoyable yes yes exactly well I mean
you can by the way argue for a similar
functional benefit of religion itself
right so
irrespective of whether religion is
false or true if we conjure up Pascal's
wager and he basically says hey look you
know you could believe in God or not
believe in God and he could exist or not
exist let's look at each of these cells
I mean he didn't use that language but
let's look at all these cells and it
turns out just believe and so that's
what you're saying look there are
different mindsets I can take all other
things considered adopt the positive one
you can't lose I'll give you a very uh
you know banal anecdote that kind of
captures that positive mindset I I
actually mentioned it in the book so uh
I can't remember I think it was two
Winters ago when the story happened
uh our heater that's in the basement
broke down now this is in Montreal
Montreal has very rough Winters and so
it was Saturday morning
the house is freezing we my wife goes
down to the basement she says oh oh I
think we have to call a repair guy and
so on so now we're driving whatever to
go see whatever it is and now I'm pissed
because I'm missing the Premiership
because you know there's some soccer
match that I really want to watch now
I'm going to waste my time now I'm gonna
waste money so I'm I'm now in a in a in
a well of being pissed off and then she
says you know what think of it this way
it's good that it happened early in the
winter when it's not too cold yet
imagine if this happened in two months
from now and it I just I took the pill I
took my wife's bill I was like you know
you're right so look how trivial and
banal that example is but Simply Having
that right mindset snaps you out of your
you know your your well of anger also
another argument for being around people
with sunny dispositions or dispositions
like the one that you want also another
argument for being in a partnership
where you have somebody that can deal
with the heater breaking together
because it's not just you and your cats
yeah I am
that's such a that's a really nice
illustration and I think as well you
know when you fold in the regret
minimization framework uh or or regret
minimization generally
you realize that what ultimately matters
is time and your attention during that
time where was your attention captured
what what were you focused on and you
have a number of days left with your
wife right that might be thousands tens
of thousands it might be 20
right but the point being that you had
an opportunity to spend time with the
person that you've decided you want to
spend the rest of your life with and
that gift reframed the way that you
spent that drive oh are you now is it
now a beautiful funny story about oh and
we stopped off to get coffee and we did
this thing or was it you almost it was
so banal and so irritating that your
memory literally can't bring it to the
surface when you request it to happen
yes I beautifully said by the way those
those
magical moments I'm I mean I'm I'm
building on what you just said so I'm
I feel them not just with my wife I have
felt them with my children and actually
it led me at one point to a
because you were mentioning earlier or
you might have 30 000 days left or 20
days left and so on and so I experienced
a temporary uh depressive state which is
extremely rare for me because I truly am
someone with a very sunny affable
disposition when I realized that my
daughter had
until until genetically developmentally
had passed the stage of playing with her
dolls she had become too old to play
with her dolls and I I'm not I'm telling
you something very personal here Chris I
literally went to something Akin of a
mourning process where I you know my
wife was saying what's wrong with you
and and I yeah I have to tell her well
I'm super sad because my daughter will
not play with it and now here's what
made it even more sad but it
demonstrates the beauty of having
children hopefully sensitive children
when my daughter realized that I was
going through that those feelings of
those painful moments
she said well Daddy let's let's go and
wait no it's if you manage to keep dry
eyes when your daughter that's grown out
of her dolls decides to go play with
them again because she wants to make you
happy no way exactly I would be in tears
but maybe I just want to make sure
though that your tears are for the same
reason my tears were not because she's
so lovely which is yes that's true it
was that as she was doing that ritual I
realized even more how strained it was
for us to be doing that so I was crying
of Greater sound dude so interesting so
so you know but but guess what
that magical moment is worth more than
all of my degrees and fancy accolades
and all the things that I
I'd like to think that you think I'm
full boasting about and all the
grandiosity it's when your daughter
looks at you when you get off stage as
she did and I'm only mentioning daughter
but my son is just as sensitive and just
as lovely uh when I get off the stage
after a big talk
and she hugged me this was two years ago
about a year and a half ago and she said
Oh Daddy I am so proud of you that was
more important than all of my fancy
colleagues saying oh I love your work so
children yes they're annoying yes
they're a pain in the ass but that's a
thicken to happiness
talk to me we've kind of spoken about
um a lot of this stuff in isolation or
at least in the family unit at the
moment
um how can people be more anti-fragile
you know there is going to be
catastrophe that will come there will be
criticism and judgment from others
especially if you want to do something
slightly different if you are going to
be following the authenticity and trying
to minimize the deathbed regrets that's
going to cause you to do more different
things than what most people do because
most people have those regrets and if
you don't want to have them you're going
to have to do the thing most people
aren't doing exactly so how do you deal
with the Judgment the criticism and how
can people become more anti-fragile well
the first thing that you can do in in
answering that question is to look as I
did in the book to look at the greatest
people of all time in different spheres
and demonstrate that their trajectory
was littered with obstacles heartaches
failures so Lionel Messi you're too
small and frail to even be a
professional soccer player let alone the
greatest soccer player of all time oh
Michael Jordan we're cutting you from
your sophomore high school team he was
cut from his high school team okay uh JK
Rowling greatest most selling author of
all best-selling author of all time
rejected by every publisher until the
last publisher accepted her oh Steven
Spielberg rejected not once not twice
but three times from the USC Film School
oh yeah that was a good choice that was
a good admission decision so imagine if
each of those guys and there are many
many others Zinedine Zidane the greatest
French player of all time what when he
could have played either for Algeria or
France the Algerian coach looked at him
and said yeah that guy is too slow oh
yeah that was a good decision coach so
imagine if all each of these guys did
not have the built-in anti-fragility to
failure that says I'm going to one day
shove it up your ass I'm going to prove
you wrong and they said you know what
yeah screw it let's pack it in we would
have never known the magic of all these
people so just that story in itself
should tell you that if the greatest of
all time in these very different domains
could be littered with failure with
rejections with obstacles then why is it
any different for you just get back on
the horse and do it again
have you looked into Salvador Dali much
well it's funny you say this I we just
went six months ago to the Salvador Dali
Museum in St Petersburg
what's it like it's beautiful it was a
bit underwhelming in that I felt that we
didn't see enough works for the amount
of time we waited in line so the cost
benefit ratio was not great it was
gorgeous but what I I don't think I
understand the link of your Dolly what
is it so dolly for the people that want
someone new to obsess about and kind of
learn about their life dolly is one of
the most interesting people that I've
researched so his parents had a child
that was born about nine and a half
months before Dali was born and they
called his older brother Salvador and
that brother died
two days after birth so his parents
believed that Salvador was The
Reincarnation of his dead old oh my God
I got goosebumps crazy so uh you know
that when that's the way that you get
brought into the world you're not going
to be a normal person I mean I'm this is
a guy who said I don't do drugs I am
drugs right and he at sort of age 10 uh
found out that he loved masochism he was
a masochist so he would throw himself
down the stairs at age 10 he would just
jump and fall downstairs he once gave a
live talk in a deep sea diving suit that
you had to be wrenched out of part way
through because he was suffocating
because he hadn't actually put it
together he fell in love with this woman
he was married and he fell in love with
a woman
who he immediately called his Muse he
said that this was the the well where
all of his inspiration had been coming
from even before he'd known her uh she
was married he was married they both
leave their Partners they get into a a
relationship and they get married
immediately as soon as they get into a
relationship he buys her a castle and
starts treating her like royalty so in
order for him to go visit the wife in
the castle that he just bought for her
he needed to send a formal invitation
request which she then needed to reply
to my point being you have this guy who
is just you know
eccentricities falling out of him left
right in the center but
he also was one of the most
revolutionary artists of the sort of
semi-modern era and the only way that he
was able to become this sort of
impressionist Legend was for him to
fully imbibe and and accept all of the
uniquenesses and the idiosyncrasies that
he had
and that's why I think that you know you
look at the the Michael Jordan Michael
was vengeful he was petty he was
um an unbelievably hard worker but he
was a tyrant both to his own team and to
everybody else's and that
the allowance of doing of every little
bit of you coming together to be as much
of you as you can be allows you to
maximize what you can show to the world
you know because it's brilliant as they
were Michelangelo didn't do Dali right
and da Vinci didn't do Dali so the only
way that we get Dali is for him to
completely embody everything that he is
you know so that that's a thank you for
that story that I'm gonna have to add
Salvador Valley on my long list of
biographies that I have to read and I've
got already like 80 in the queue so
you've just added one more uh but that
speaks to an earlier point we're talking
about when we're talking about know
thyself and authenticity and so on uh
one of the things that I mentioned in
the book at one point so I I talked
earlier about the regret of not having
become a professional soccer player to
the maximum of my talent the another
regret that I briefly mentioned is I
often wondered whether I should regret
the fact that I am irascible the fact
that I just beat to walk to my own drum
the fact that I don't care what people
think because oh maybe if I had been
more modulated in my career risk band
then I would have gotten that
professorship that I wanted in Southern
California and I remember I was sharing
that story with Megan Kelly this is all
discussed in the book and uh she looked
at me and like any good therapist would
do she says
but those are the exact traits that made
millions of people
gravitate towards you it it is that
nature it's the part irrational part
spicy part funny part grandiose but that
and so I thought you know what that's
that's true don't question who you are
just assume it fully and let the chips
fall where they may
let's get Tactical for a moment sure
interventions for happiness you're not a
prescription guy but you are in some
regards what would you say
uh well so go through some of those key
Secrets yes uh always try to find this
sweet spot in whichever Pursuit you do
and let me give an example where I
haven't found it yet uh I perfectionism
the trait of perfectionism follows an
inverted you if you're not at all
perfectionist your work will suffer
you're not attentive to details if you
are excessively perfectionist as I am
way over The Sweet Spot you end up
reading your Galley proofs for your
forthcoming book for 4 680 days because
God forbid there might be one typo or
one comma out of place well guess what
had you not spent all that time doing
that and started working on your next
book idea that time would have been
better spent so that's a that's a place
where I haven't yet improved I try I'm
mindful of it I want to defeat it but
it's very difficult for me to get out of
that behavioral trap or that
psychological mindset so for most
Pursuits in life finding The Sweet Spot
is exactly what will get you to your
flourishing maximal point
seek variety
as much as you can and a monogamous
Union it might be challenging to seek
variety but food variety I talk a lot
about intellectual variety seeking which
speaks to also our discussion on
Academia in Academia you are expected to
be a stay in your lane Professor you are
a hyper specialist you know a lot about
something very very small keep pumping
out 9 000 different papers all of which
are pure all of which only
three four people care about but boy are
you a specialist because you've built
economies of scale you know the
literature you know the methodology so
it's going to take you very little to
create that plus Epsilon study whereas
I've done the exact opposite of my
career I have published in medicine and
politics and evolutionary psychology and
marketing and consumer behavior and
bibliometric why because I'm like a kid
in a candy store if you propose an idea
that I go oh that's interesting I don't
have the calculus that says but no this
is what I should do this is not what I
should do now some might say well I lose
because they then I in in Academia they
don't reward you for being
interdisciplinarian as actually a
university that was going to hire me in
Southern California told me they said
the the weakness in your CV is that you
seem to be all over the place whereas I
said but I thought that would be the
strong point of my CV and so life is too
short from my perspective there are many
intellectual Landscapes that I wish to
visit and therefore I don't want to keep
going back to the same exact spot so
variety seeking minimized regret through
the anticipatory regret mechanism choose
the right spouse choose the right
profession which by the way we didn't
discuss if I can very quickly
I argue that the best way to have
purpose and meaning in your profession
is anything that allows you to
instantiate your creativity impulse so a
chef a stand-up comic a podcaster an
architect an author are in completely
different domains but they are all doing
one thing in common which is creating
new material new bridge a new dish a new
stand-up routine a new book a new
podcast and so when you immerse yourself
in that creative process by definition
it it's going to Grant you purpose and
meaning so those are some of the key
ones that I'm thinking off top of my
head
Dr gadsad ladies and gentlemen where
should people go they want to keep up to
date with the stuff that you're doing uh
my website godside
g-a-d-s-a-a-d.com I'm on Twitter same
name and if you'd like to purchase my
book you can get it on Amazon the sad
truth about happiness eight secrets for
leading the good life if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe